Mẹ a mẹ thành chiến tổng thống ảnh Quốc li trên miang đưa ra kể báo sang.
Cô ra này có thể phải đối mặt với một cuộc khủng hoảng tay chính nghiêm trang.
Nếu không có biển táb vào đam khi chiến khai các sự án đầu từ lớn vào Mỹ,
theo thời thần không đặt được hội thống bẩy.
Sôn cám kết đầu từ 8 trân lâm y tìa đô lâm y tương đương,
phần lớn dự trứng hỏi hủ hiện có.
Tuy nhiên, ông li nhấn mạnh, viện dút lượng, tình mặt không lâu này.
Là không khả thị, nếu thiếu cứ cơ trế tay chính án toàn,
chúng đó hiệp định hoảng đổi tình tại được calla thêm chốt,
bây giờ tôi cũng hủng hoảng lâm y tình chính trang chính bầy.
Vốn khi nhanh Quốc phải cầu viện của ý tình tại Cô tầy e-mèf
tế tục lòng một lời nhấn nhật sốt sàng.
Bây giờ, chính của anh của chờ biến đàn lượng đầy nghen các cuộc đam phản thương mại với Washington.
Nhanh tạo không pháp liệu định cho các sự án.
Vào các bạn sẽ trở sẵn tình báo của ông li,
phần án xử lo ngại ngày kàng xa thăng,
chứ các lực cân bằng dưới nhu cầu vực tác chỉ lượng Mỹ,
và báo đam án cho đền tại chính cú xa.